Hello! Welcome to Asakusa, a traditional part in Tokyo.
Today, we will be trying two of Asakusa's animal cafes.
The cafes are interesting to visit for Japanese and tourist families.
Here we go!
Welcome to Asakusa's cat cafe called Manta.
This here is one of the ten cats who live here in this cafe.
The cafe is a great place for families and children to explore...
...and have a cold drink on a hot day.
Here you can see some of the cats playing with each other on a wooden structure.
The cats have very soft fur and love to be touched.
Hi there.
Welcome to Asakusa's "Jungle Cafe."
This cafe has tons of owls, otters...
...and all types of animals ranging from snakes to little birds.
It's a great place to visit in Asakusa.
This Great African Parrot can speak Japanese and even sing!
We hope you enjoyed today's tour of Asakusa's animal cafes.
Bye-bye and see you soon!